hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast identification of preexisting
adaptive immune responses to cows 9 in
humans it is presented by Carsten
charlesworth who's a PhD student in stem
cell biology and regenerative medicine
at Stanford University I am Judy
O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab Rhodes
laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars so before you begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box which is
located on the far left of your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box that appears on the screen
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Carsten charlesworth I will now turn the
presentation over to him hi so yeah as
Judy introduced I'm Carson and I'm here
in Stanford University and the Institute
for stem-cell regenerative medicine and
today I'm going to be talking about some
work that we recently published earlier
this year in January on bio archives as
a preprint publication and is currently
under review in Nature Medicine where we
have identified the existence of
pre-existing adaptive immune responses
to cast 9 in humans so as many of you as
probably all of you are aware since
you're following along with this webinar
the crisper cast 9 system has become a
very powerful tool for genome editing
and is being roughly applied towards the
treatment of genetic disease either
through the delivery
the crisper cast line system into cells
ex-vivo so you edit cells and then into
in graph those edited cells back into
application to treat some form of
disease or through the packaging the
coastlines the CRISPR cast line system
into other nanoparticles or viral
vectors to deliver it directly into
patients to then perform in vivo genome
editing to treat some form of disease
and many groups are rushing forward to
apply the CRISPR cast line system plea
to treat many different diseases for
instance and Duchenne muscular dystrophy
sickle-cell disease and even the first
clinical trial involving the CRISPR past
9 system has been approved in the US
however the most common for common
homologs of cast 9 that most people are
working with I derived from
streptococcus pyogenes and
Staphylococcus aureus s pyogenes is the
bacteria that causes strep throat and as
aureus is the bacteria that causes staph
infections the resin is talk I'm going
to be referring to these two homologs of
cast 9 as SP cast line the homologue
derived from s pyogenes and sa cast 9
for the homologue derived from S aureus
S aureus and the s pyogenes cast 9 is
typically used for in vitro editing and
it was a first cast 9 that was really
applied towards genome editing and the S
aureus cast line is a more recent
variant of cast line that has been
developed and is typically applied
towards in vivo editing as it's smaller
packaging smaller protein size allows it
to be more easily packaged into viral
vectors for delivery into patients in
vivo oh one minute groups are making a
lot of progress on potentially treating
genetic disease using these two hormones
of cast 9 the bacteria that they come
from our common human pencils and often
human pathogens as pyogenes and habits
roughly 20% of the population at any
given time and in an SLR aureus inhabits
roughly 40 percent of the population at
any given time and if you look for
antibodies against these bacteria and P
cell responses against these bacteria
basically anyone who's over the age of
18 has antibodies and T cells against
these bacteria and so given that
antibody are given that a pre-existing
immunity to both of these bacteria is
very common into the pocket in the
population we also call it the question
is it possible that during our normal
lifespans that we develop immunity to
cast line protein as a result of
exposure to these bacteria either
through cast 9 from these bacteria being
taken up by a VSO which then goes on to
make plasma cells which make antibodies
that are specific against cast 9 or your
cast line being taken up by an Adu
presenting cells in a person which then
go on to activate naive t-cells which
produce memory and effector T cells as a
result now for therapeutic genome
editing the presence of antibodies
against cast 9 may not necessarily be a
cause for concern
anybody's anybody's in the bloodstream
boo neutralize anything in the
bloodstream so who's anybody's against
the specific virus that you're using as
a vector to deliver cast 9 they would
not likely neutralize the virus however
since pretty much old methodologies that
involve using the CRISPR Cassadine
system to treat disease currently
involve in inserting cast line into
cells
this shouldn't be a concern however the
existence of T souls against cast line
could be a concern for Cal for genome
editing particularly for in vivo genome
editing as and as T cells will recognize
any soul that has cast line inside of it
as the side of the souls that received
cast iron will present pieces of cast
line on their surface and the T cells
will respond if they are antigen
specific to cast line will respond by
releasing cytokines that kill cells that
have cast line inside of them thus if
you are for instance doing Inigo genome
editing and delivery cast line to the
liver if you have T cells that recognize
cells that have cast line inside of them
they will clear the souls that receive
cast line width and will likely cause a
loss of any kind of therapeutic effects
as any of the Saudi genome edited will
be removed from the body sorry well well
anybody's against cast 9 are not
necessarily a concern for therapeutic
genome editing to determine if there
were antigen specific t-cells against
cast 9 we first looked to see if we
could detect antibodies that were
specific against cast 9 in the human
population as anybody's a significantly
easier to detect than t-cell responses
and the detection of antibodies against
caste 9 in the regular human population
would be indicative of the fact that
human immune systems are both exposed to
caste 9 and therefore likely also have a
t-cell response against caste 9 a
pre-existing t-score responsibly up
against caste 9 I said a little cliff
look for more responses to caste 9 or
antibody responses the pre-existing
antibody responses to the caste line we
first use an immunoblot approach and so
in the immunoblot approach we blot one
microgram by the castle and homologue
onto a PVDF membrane we then block the
membrane with milk and then incubate the
membrane with human serum diluted at 1
to 10 over 9 so in this case human serum
is essentially serving as a primary
antibody against caste 9 we then
incubate the membrane with anti human SC
antibody conjugated to horseradish
peroxidase diluted a 1 to 5 thousand and
then we developed the block and if there
are antibodies against caste 9 in the
human serum what we expect to see is a
clear band it will we expect to see is a
bad forecast 9 in the resulting blot
that we develop and so what I'm showing
you here are the results from 34 donors
and this is a figure in the preprint
that we published in January where we
feel and where we saw a variety of
different antibody responses to cast
line and different donors but what I
want to focus you on is a couple of
specific donors that we found responses
to caste 9 so what you can see here is a
very very differences in against the
different homologs of caste 9 between
donors for instance if you focus in on
donor and 321 found on the Left B you
can see that this donor had serum that
could very clearly bind to detect S
aureus caste 9 and detected SP caste 9
to a much weaker extent if you look at
donor 3 to 3 on the right you can see
that donor 3 to 3
clearly had antibodies against s
pyogenes caste 9 while there is no
detectable response against S aureus
caste 9 and if you look on the very
right at Dartmouth 325 you can see that
this donor had
no detectable levels of manacle
anybody's by Westham lot against either
the progenies homolog of caste line or
the aureus home along with caste nine at
least by Western blot having found that
we can clearly detect antibodies against
caste nine in human population we next
set up an Eliza to try and detect ad to
see today detect antibodies against
caste 9 because analyzer is both
quantitative and it allows for much more
high-throughput screening for donors to
see if there are pre-existing humoral
responses to caste 9 so in the print the
principle of Eli's is that you have a
plate which you will then put your
antigen in it you'll put your antigen of
interest into in this case we're putting
caste 9 the plate will get coated with
caste 9 protein you can block empty
spots on the plate and then what you
have is a plate that has cast line
coated all over it and then what you'll
do is you wash the plate and then you
introduce serum from that your from
whatever donor you're interested in
looking at and if the donor that you're
looking at has antibody specific against
caste 9 those anybody's will police will
find specifically to cast line in the
play and then wash out the serum and if
there are specific antibodies they'll
remain on the caste line and then you
can introduce your secondary antibody
which is specific against human which is
specific against human antibodies and
will be conjugated to horseradish
peroxidase again you wash the plate and
then finally you can develop the plate
with substrate and if there are
anybody's at buying caste 9 on the
second year and then the secondary
antibodies that bind those antibodies
defying council 9 the substrate will
change color in the plate and you can
measure this absorbance at 450
nanometers and determine you know yeah
if there are antibodies against caste
line and how high the titer of
antibodies is in a given individual and
so we first went titer the rate the
amount of serum to use on on our Eliezer
for different for different donors here
what we did is we use tennis toxoids a
positive control to detect people with
digit to detect antibodies as almost
everyone has anybody's against tetanus
toxoid is we almost all receive receive
our tetanus vaccinate vaccination once
every 10 years and then we use human
Avilan which is a protein commonly found
in blood as a negative
trol as we shouldn't be able to detect
any kind of antibodies against the human
protein which is common in the blood at
the top of each of these graphs that you
can see in the in this slide it's is the
dilution of serum that we used to to
probe with so in the top left we we
dilutes a human serum one to ten to
probe for any human antibodies against
tetanus toxoid human human sa cast line
and SP cast line and in the bottom right
we use the dilution of one to one
thousand of human serum to detect each
of the different antigens and what you
can see is that at each different
titration that we use you can see a
significant difference in the absorbance
when tetanus toxoid sa cast line at our
SP cast nine is being probed against
versus our negative control human
albumin so after having titer the level
of level of serum to use for our Eliza
we next performed a wider screen using a
serum dilution of one to fifty we use a
serum dilution of one to fifty as it
gave us the most dynamic range in
absorbances and also because it's a very
common dilution of serum to use when
looking for specific anacott antibodies
against any kind of antigen and so what
you can see here on the right on the
right figure is that we are able to
again see a clear statistically
significant increase in the frequency in
the absorbance of from our lives of
plates when we have sa cast on or SVP
cast nine on on our Eliza compared to
when we look at human albumin what you
can even see very clearly you need left
is that even in the tetanus toxoid
samples where almost all donors draw
positive if you look at the bottom left
of the figure you'll see a single dot
where somebody showed up as having being
negative negative for having any kind of
antennas toxoids types of tetanus all
sort of antibodies by absorbance
indicating that they are either in
anti-vaxxer or not up to date with their
their tetanus toxoid vaccine so
determine to determine where we would
put the cutoff for what we considered a
donor that was positive for having
humoral or any and any pre-existing
antibody response to cast nine we took
the mean of the human of human samples
and then added two standard deviations
and so using this as our positive cutoff
threshold we find that 99% of the donors
that we screams we're positive for
having antibodies against tetanus toxoid
80% of donors were positive for having
antibodies against the S aureus cast
line and 56% of donors were positive for
having antibodies against SP calves 9
while 2% of human are human samples
showed up positive which you can see by
the two ball two dots there above the
dotted line we have on the graph
indicating that we do have a low a low
false positive rate or about two percent
so we have clearly detected fully shown
the we're able to detect antibodies
against cache line but as I was talking
about earlier
anybody's against caste line aren't
necessarily any impediment to using
Khattak for the CRISPR caste Alliance
system for therapeutic genome editing
what it is of much more of a concern is
are there and in specific t-cells in the
population against caste 9 and so the
first asset that we use to see if we
could detect antigen specific t-cells
against caste 9 was a cytokine capture
as they're the principle of the cytokine
a capture a say is that we take
peripheral blood mononuclear cells from
people so souls of your all of this
throwing cells all of your blood except
for your red blood cells and you get rid
of those you put all of those cells in
the culture and then you introduce your
attitude of interest in this case cast 9
what will happen is that souls in the
cells in that culture of the peripheral
blood mononuclear cells you take will
take up caste 9 and it will they will
break up cast 9 and put little fragments
of cast 9 onto the surface of themselves
if there are antigen specific T cells
present in that culture against caste 9
they will be able to recognize cast 9 on
the surface of their souls that are
presenting it and it responds to
recognizing caste 9 they were at least
different cytokines
now here we're you here what we're
looking at is specifically interferon
gamma and so T cells that respond they
respond to caste line on the surface of
other cells released in different gamma
in response to detecting detecting caste
9 we can then use a capture antibody to
the text and interferon gamma as it's
being released from integer interfere
here detects interferon gamma
is being released from t cells that are
antigen-specific to cast nine and we can
then stain for an authority from gamma
that's caught at the surface of cells
with another antibody that's attached to
a floor floor and the detect antigen
specific T cells that are releasing
interferon gamma and using flow
cytometry and so what I was showing you
showing you here as a representative
image from the prepend and put up in
January where we would ever detect a
cellular response to S aureus cast 9 but
we're not able to detect a cellular or
t-cell response to pyogenes cast 9 and
so what you can see in the very left of
the figure 8 figure is an unstable a to
control and so these are souls or
there's coaching and regular Mita media
that has 5% human serum and what you can
see is that they have very few area you
have a very low background we don't just
have to very many interferon gamma
positive cells however it's at the very
right of that you can see that when sa
cast lie is introduced into the culture
you can see that we can very clearly now
detect interferon gamma positive cells
the same thing you can see that we don't
really pick up too many pyogenes cast
line T cells over background and in the
very right is our positive control and
these are souls that was stimulated with
a viral peptide pool mix which have
viral peptides from several different
viruses such as herpes mono and a few
others and viruses that almost everyone
has been exposed to throughout the
regular lifespan and as you can see you
again here we can detect a very clear
response against the baro peptide pool
now an initial and our initial preprint
we didn't know we had not detected any
antigen specific T cells against the
pyogenes homologue of cast 9 however
shortly after our preprint another group
wagner and ammonia o published another
article published another preprint
article on bio archive where they showed
they were over detect at high
frequencies almost ubiquitously
TSP casts 9 specific t-cells which we
had not initially detected in our
preprint and so based on their findings
we decided to go back and use several
other assays to trying to kick a detect
antigen specific t-cells very thoroughly
and you figure out you know exactly what
kind of frequencies we were able to find
them at and if we can detect SP casts 9
T cells in particular so there are 3
different
we focus on the detects detects antigen
specific t-cells against the two home
along with cats 9 we use intracellular
as I kind the cytokine staining which I
have up here is interested cytokine
capture assay as a type would we use we
also look to see if we could detect
souls that were Annan is specific by
activation markers since when T so a
Nativity so you become activated when
they encounter their specific antigen it
will put C 137 or C 154 or both onto
their so under their surface which we
can detect by by staying it by staining
and flow cytometry and then finally we
use analyze spot assay to try and detect
any specific t-cells against the two
homologous and so first I'm going to
talk about our results from performing
interest of a cytokine a sustaining to
trying to check adamant specific t-cells
in its cast 9 and so the workflow for
intracellular cytokine staining or ICS
is that we take peripheral blood
mononuclear cells will be frozen down we
fill them out
we then allow them to rest overnight and
then I laughter line them to rest we'll
add in our respective antigen and so in
this case we used as a positive control
tetanus toxoid and then we sa cast line
SP pass line and then the unstimulated
control is just in media with 5 percent
human serum we put in our antigens for
two hours and then after two hours we
add for Feldon a and preferred na is a
goalie inhibitor and so if there are any
t souls that are responding to the
antigens we'll put in there and i'm
producing cytokines or as a result since
there are going can't operate properly
these cytokines will start booting up in
their goalie and after four hours of
adding so adding the per photon a we can
then perform intracellular cytokines
spending to look for the cytokines that
have built up inside itself once we've
stained intracellularly for these
cytokines we can then analyze for
cytokine positive t cell by flow
cytometry and so our gaining to detect
two antigen specific t-cells by by
looking for inches by eight by eight
Rossella estoy con standing is that so
the very left you can see that we we
this gate specifically on the lymphocyte
population
we then gate on live cells and then to
the very light it's the very right you
can see we gates on sorry
on single souls then we get on live
cells and you can see you to the very
look very right and we use a live dead
fixable who's saying to determine live
cells versus dead cells
we then gate on CD three positive cells
and then when we harness specifically on
the cd4 positive and cd8 positive T
cells and then for the very left you can
see the very at the very end we are
looking at cd4 positive cd8 positive T
cells that are either pod that are
positive for TNF alpha aisle to or
interfering gamma all cytokines that
t-cells release in response to being
stimulated by their specific antigen so
what I'm showing you here in the in this
and this slide is representative flow
cytometry images from a donor that
showed up being positive it showed up as
being positive for both having antigen
specific t-cells against sa coastline
and SP cast nine donor 219 so the very
top left is our unstimulated control and
what you can see is that in or on
stimulate control you can see that there
are almost no souls that are showing up
as being cytokine positive for either
interferon gamma TNF alpha or how to so
very load backgrounds now to the right
of that you can see that are not
positive control the tetanus toxoid
birth control well you can see that
there are souls trail you can see that
there are lots of them not that there
are some cells or tion comes in from
gamma positive tina alpha positive and
or royalty or and i'll to positive now
while there aren't that many cells are
showing up this is to be expected
antigen specific t-cells are very rare
annual blood stream to any particular
antigen you would expect to find antigen
specific t-cells in the blood stream at
point zero one to two points sorry point
one to point zero one percent of your
total t cell populations so they're very
rare now if you look down in the bottom
to two panels of this figure you can see
that when we add as a cast line or as
PCAST line to our premium c population
that we have a we have we have a
significant increase in the number of
t-cells that are positive for having a
different gamma TNF alpha or il-2
compared to the unstimulated control now
we perform this assay on 18 different
donors and then we
this is the water I'm showing you here
is the results from all of these 18
different diets so to the right is to
the right of this fit of this of this
panel and this is the figure that are
showing the percent of different
cytokines diff different T cells that
show up with the different cytokines
different gamma I'll - TNF alpha and you
can see that the average in all cases
whether you're introducing sa cast line
SP cast line or tetanus toxoid is above
the unstimulated control and to the left
what I'm showing you is the total number
of cytokine positive T cells so this is
tallying up all the T cells that showed
up as being a different gamma positive I
all too positive interfering gamma and
il-2 positive and just putting them as
what percentage they all the cytokine
positive T cells make up off the of the
holes T cell population and so what you
can see again is that all the averages
are back our above background and
they're all statistically significant
although I forgot to put bars on this
chart and so the way that we determine
whether or not we could we were a
specific donor was positive for having a
cytokine response in response to each of
our different antigens is very similar
to the way that we set our cutoff for
Eliza so we took the mean of the
unstimulated control and then we added
two standard deviations and that was our
cutoff for whether or not a donor was
considered positive and so that little
dotted line you're seeing in the left
figure is whether or not a particular
donor was considered positive and using
that as like Coughlin cut off that
threshold we detected 50% of our donors
as being had has had a detectable level
of cytokine response and response to
tetanus toxoid being introduced know
that we had no false false positives at
the unstimulated control a 66% of donors
showed up as being positive for having a
cytokine response to S aureus cast nine
and forty four percent of donors showed
up as having of cytokine response to SP
cast nine and so what we have definitely
has some false negatives and most likely
in the tetanus toxoid control we're
definitely seeing is a clear cytokine
response in into sa cast iron or SP cast
line being introduced in particular
donut into two particular Donuts so in
our original preprint
we have not detected SP cast nine
specific t-cells they're just following
up with just the intracellular cytokine
acid we've clearly detected and in
specific t-cells of the cast nine and so
you next I say that we looked at and
tried was to see if we could detect an
ana specific t-cells looking at the
activation Marcos CD 137 and C 154 and
these are the two CD 137 in particular
is one of the activation marcus was
always used in the other creme print
that i had mentioned when they were
looking for anis but they detected as
for the t-cells against SP cast line
pretty much ubiquitously in every donor
that they had tested and so the workflow
for this assay is pretty similar to that
of thought that's done for the
interstellar cytokine staying so we take
frozen PBMCs that we have we pull them
out rest them overnight and then we add
each of the different antigens in the
culture with with our PBMCs we then let
the PBM C's in culture for 16 hours with
each specific antigen and after 16 hours
will stain fours will stain purses for
at the surface of cells CD 137 and CD
154 and they're not sustaining them
again we analyze by flow cytometry and
then gating for detecting CD 137 and CD
154 positive t-cells is almost exactly
the same as the intracellular cytokine
staining the only difference is we use a
different alive dead market in this case
we used a P and then instead of looking
at the different cytokines we're looking
at CED 137 and CD 154 which you can see
in the bottom left of this bigger panel
and so what I'm showing you in this
slide is the representative images from
a single positive donor donor to 1 9
which is the same donor that I was
showing you four inches fellow cytokine
savings so now you're seeing same donor
had the same results across two
different assays and so in the top left
there in the unstimulated control you
can see that while you can see that
there is some background I mean both for
both CT 137 and CT 154 so 0.12 percent
of T cells are showing up is positive
for CT 137 in the unstimulated and 0.03
one percent of T cells are showing up is
positive for CD 154 and the unstimulated
control so there's always some
background when you do this assay that's
to be expected
but to the very right of the
unstimulated control you can see that in
the tennis also in sample you can see
that they're sniffing Utley more CD 137
and seating 154 quality themselves and
similarly if you look at the bottom two
panels you can see that in the samples
that received si cast 9 + SP cast 9
they're significant more more CD 137
positive and CD 154 positive cheese
cells than the unstimulated control and
so again we screened 18 donors looking
for an increase in the frequency of
activation Marcos in t-cells when we
introduce each of our different antigens
compared to the unseemly control and so
on the left you can see that it we had a
significantly higher percentage of CD
137 positive t-cells compared to our
unstimulated control when we introduced
s a cast iron is P cast line or tetanus
toxoid indoor our samples and similarly
on our in our in the right panel you can
see that when we introduce SP cast line
compared to the unseemly control we have
a significant increase and when we
introduce tetanus toxoid into into our
sample we have a seeming increase
alright when we chose s a cache line we
didn't have statistically significant
increase in CD 154 but you know the
p-value is fluid above p point zero 5
you can very clearly see that there are
some donors it is significantly above
above the background of the onsubmit
control um
compared to the wagner preprint that I
was talking about earlier we don't see
quite as large of an increase in the
frequency of CD 137 positive t-cells as
what they found is which is what I'm
showing you tuning right here when we
introduce SP casts 9 we do find it
successfully sediment difference this
could just be due to differences in
processing for instance we use frozen
cells which are known to stimulate less
than freshly hast the T cells which is
what they used in their study it could
be a methodology it could be in staining
it couldn't even just be a different in
our donors difference in the darkness
that we hadn't had available however if
we take the background CD 137 positive T
cells and the background of CD 154
positive T cells that
we're able to detect and then subtract
that from each of the samples that
receives each of the different antigens
what you can see is that in almost all
samples there was a higher frequency of
City 137 positive or city 154 positive T
cells over background so if you look at
city 137 almost 100 100 percent of
samples had a greater than background
frequency of city 137 positive T cells
when you introduce tetanus toxoid 88%
when you introduce sa cast 9 100% when
you in shoes SP cast 9 similarly when
you do when you look at city 1 54
percent of positive T cells you can see
that they're 94% of 94 percent of donors
were above background for city 150 450
94 percent when you introduce sa cast
line and 88 percent when you introduce
SP cast 9 all of the dots that you can
see the very bottom of the y-axis are
set where it's set to 0.001
those are samples that were at or below
the unstimulated control and we're just
set to their bottom of the graph here
but we can clearly see is that there's
an increase in both of these activation
markers when you're introduced in all
three of these antigens again indicating
that there are definitely antigen
specific t-cells in the population
against both sa cast line and SP cast 9
and then finally the last assay that we
use to look for antigen specific t-cells
you know in different donors against sa
cast line and as PKS line is analyzed by
assay and this is my personal favorite
assay for looking for an engine specific
t-cells not only because it's the
easiest to perform but also because it
gives you the most clear indicator
visually that there are antigen specific
t-cells in a sample and so that's the
last one I'm going to be talking about
right now
and so the workflow fertilized spot is
fairly similar to that of the Eliza so
we'll have a plate that has a piece of
filter paper at the very bottom of it I
started off filter paper a piece of
paper at the very bottom of it and on
that piece of paper will be anti
interferon gamma antibodies that are
being pre coded
onto the play then what we can do is we
can take our PBMCs from which ever done
or we're interested in looking at and
put them onto the plate and then we'll
add whatever antigen we're interested in
studying into the play with these cells
we then incubate the cells with what a
random we're interested in for two days
and if there are antigen specific T
cells present in that population that we
put in their plate they're going to
react to souls that have taken up that
antigen and release in afferent gamma in
the process anybody is at the very very
bottom of the plate are going to be able
to pick up and hold on to the interferon
gammas that they release surrounding
them so little B little little spots
wherever there are T cells releasing
different gamma of anybody's that are
now bound to in in ferret that have now
bound interfering gamma home plate after
two days will wash out the T cells and
the media that we put on the plate and
then we'll add then introduce our
primary antibody which is another
antibody that's specific for interferon
gamma and so any any spots on the plate
or interferon gamma will bind our
primary antibody will then bind and our
primary antibody is conjugated to biotin
we will then wash the plate and then
introduce streptavidin conjugated to
alkaline phosphatase and so any other
places where the primary antibody has
behind now stripped I have an income
conjugated to alkaline phosphatase is
gonna bind on the plate we can wash
everything out again and then finally
what we end up with is any place where
interferon gamma has bound on the plate
we're going to get spots where a primary
antibody and then strip that in
conjugate alcohol phosphatase will have
bound and it'll be just particular spots
on the plate we can then introduce our
stubs to substrate and any areas where
there have been where our secondary
antibody has bound duty and the presence
of interferon gamma the alkaline
phosphatase is going to react with the
substrate we introduce to result in a
substrate that's going to get deposited
right around the areas where ever there
have been either wherever interferon
gamma has been found and once we wash
everything out and wash it away when we
end up with so is a plate is a plate
with a little piece of paper at the
bottom
and I'm not on that piece of paper
you're going to be seeing little blue
spots and each one of those spots
represents an area where a single Tissot
has been releasing interferon gamma in
response to a specific antigen and so
one spot equals one antigen specific T
cell and so this is a representative
image is from what this looks like when
you get to the end of this assay and so
these representative in this
representative images are again from the
same donor donor to 1/9 so you're seeing
the same donor is showing up positive
across multiple different assays and so
you can see to the very left and the
unstimulated control you have 3 3 blue
dots on the plate whereas in the SI caps
mine as PCAST line and Tenace toxoid
cells and you've been constantly
coaching with those antigens you're
seeing many many more spots and so the
way we would analyze this data is we
would take the number of spots that were
found let's say in the SA cast 9 well
and then we would subtract the number of
stars are in the unstimulated control
sorry in the sa cast 9 s a cast iron
wall you find 20 spots then you would
subtract 3 so you would say that there
are 17 spot forming cells in that well
and since we put 500,000 cells in each
well the way that we tabulate that data
is it would be 17 spot forming cells her
500,000 cells and so what I'm showing
you in this this slide right here is the
results from doing this assay on 18
different donors again and what you can
see and so what we've done is we
subtracted the unstimulated from all of
them want all of these samples that have
received antigen and you can see that
there there are definitely a lots of
donors that have that I have you know
numbers of spot forming cells that are
above the unassimilated control so are
all the 18 donors that we screened 77%
had a greater than background for a
number of spots for SA cast 9 50% for SP
cast 9 and then 100 % when tetanus
toxoid was introduced now which is
always remarkably right about where the
frequency of which we find anybody's
against cast 9 in the population now
what
the other thing on this graph is if you
look at the red dots that are on this
graph
those are all samples that are not found
to be statistically significant either
because there was mostly because there's
just too much variance in between the
different samples so of the of all the
different donors that we screened 55%
had a statistically significant greater
than the background number of spot
forming cells than the on stimuli
control 33% when we introduced SP cast
line and 78% when we introduced tetanus
toxoid but finally you know we've
clearly been protecting antigen specific
t-cells against caste mind that as I was
talking about before antigen specific
t-cells ian's any antigen are very rare
and so the signal you get from molasses
is very weak and so to validate that all
of these assays that we've been doing
have actually been detecting antigen
specific t-cells against any particular
antigen the last thing we do is we take
those adding these rare antigen specific
t-cells we specifically isolate them out
and then expand them and then what we
can do is we can relate them and the
idea is is that once you have you know
expanded population of this when you re
stimulate this we're stimulate that
population whatever signal you get at
the very end should be very very clear
I'm sorry to expand and then to isolate
expand Andry stimulate my antigen
specific t-cells against any antigen but
you know particularly for Kassai in this
case what we do is we take a tube and we
introduce PBMCs again and then we'll
introduce our antigen and then off the
16 hours we'll do what we did before for
the activation mocker well will then
take those cells and stain on the
extracellular surface of the cell for
the presence of CD 137 and CD 154 we
then saw these activated t-cells by flow
cytometry take these activated t-cells
and then we'll culture them on a
radiated peripheral blood mononuclear
cells from the same donor and the reason
we cultured them on a radiated
peripheral blood mononuclear cells is
that you know these these T cells need
certain signals and cytokines from those
from those same cells that we were
radiated and we irradiated them to
prevent the of these cells that we
introduced from expanding as well so
that the only thing
expanding and culture is the T cells
that we've plated and Whitney's
irradiated pfcs culture these T cells
that we've isolated for a period of 10
days and then presence of aisle 2 and
then what we'll end up with is an
expanded population of T cells we can
then take these T cells and then
recently them with with PBMCs from the
same donor that have been depleted of T
cells using in max depletion so that now
these T seals that we've expanded are
introduced with everything with PBMCs
from the same donor except there are no
T cells so that when we do flow
cytometry the only T cells that were
looking at are the T cells that we've
expanded in culture will then introduce
the specific antigen that the T cells
should be specific for and then after
then we can do intracellular cytokine
staining and what we would expect to see
is that we have you know most of these T
cells that we've expanded should have a
strong cytokine response in after after
being Reston lated with their specific
antigen and so what I'm showing you here
is the results from our East emulation
and so on the left are sa cast nine
specific T cells that have been isolated
and expanded over a period of ten days
and on the right are SP cast lines and T
cells which have been isolated and
expanded now on the on the top slide is
sa cast line and SP cast line specific
t-cells that re simulated with tetanus
toxoid so if you look at the top half of
the the facts panels you can see that
there is very low levels of cytokines
being produced in these t cells when
they re stimulated with tetanus toxoid
which is not the antigen their specific
form but if you look at the bottom panel
when you re simulate sa cast line
specific t-cells with sa cast nine you
have a market a very notable increase in
the frequency of cytokine positive
t-cells and the same thing when you
reintroduce SP cast lines of T cells
with SP cast nine for instance and we
look at you know one single one single
cytokine if you look at sa cast line
when you introduce sa cosine specific
t-cells with tennis toxoid you have two
points three three percent of cells that
are positive at their TNF alpha positive
however when you when you choose sa cast
my specific t-cells with sa cast 942
point
2% of these T cells are now positive for
tnf-alpha demonstrating a clear antigen
specific response to sa cast 9 and so in
summary we've detected a clear we've
detected both clear humoral and so
mediated or pre-existing responses the
cast line in the population so a pretty
high frequencies the population is
essentially being pre immunized against
cats 9 looking at just you know aureus
specific responses you know we find that
we are able to detect antibodies against
s s om S aureus cast nine and eighty
percent of people we're gonna text
t-cell responses by intracellular
cytokine sitting in sixty six percent of
people t-cell responses by a live spot
and fifty-five percent of people and
then looking at activation maccas
they're induced when we introduce cast
line into into back in with with souls
we find that 88 percent of donors had an
increase in CT 137 over background and
94 percent had an increase in CD 154 of
the background and then for s pyogenes
cast on we find that we detect 56
percent of people as being positive as
measured by a negroid responses by eliza
forty four percent of people by intro so
a cytokine staining 33 percent by a live
spot and then 100 percent by an increase
in CT 137 activation and 88 percent by
an increase in CD 154 activation and so
this is pretty much all the daughter I
have to present to you today I do have a
lot of people to thank for you know
helping me to get this Purina to
presenting you know make all this Tata
you know particularly you know my my P I
matthew Porteous whose lab I did all
this work in and Daniel debo the postdoc
who you know mentored me throughout this
whole process
also Joe Camarena Kyle Kurama and Victor
LEM got all helped a lot with with
producing a lot of this data from the
Weinberg lab my my co-author Priyanka
Deshpande II and you know Ken Weinberg
who helps a lot with Dino structuring
these TESOL assays
a Chris Beck aloo wasn't mad at me for
saying is renamed wrong from ITT he and
his team produced all the protein that
we use for these assays and then finally
members of the wrong crawler lab at
Stanford here also helped a lot with you
know detecting antigens
the t-cells um and then those were most
funny goes you know I person was funded
through a certain bridges internship
which was how I was able to do all this
work and most of it was actually done
before I was even a graduate student and
then I'm of course that's the same thing
Stanford for you know gave me the
wonderful opportunity to be here and do
research at Stanford and so that is that
is it and I can take any questions Thank
You Carson for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you would like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
back your question into the box it
appears on your screen and click the
send button our speaker will follow up
with your questions via email so let's
get started our first question is what
impacts do you think these results have
on therapeutic genome editing with cows
9 for the for any kind of ex-vivo
therapy where you edit a cells XP go
outside somebody's body and then put
them back in I don't know this won't
necessarily have a significant impact on
those kinds of therapies either because
cast 9 can you know get out of set you
know by the time you apply or so you can
culture the cells long enough that cast
on will be gone from the souls when you
can graph them back in or in the case of
something like a mad according stem so
you know the bone marrow and each has
come off considered somewhat immuno
privilege so once the you're home on
pork stem cells if you edit them and put
them back in go back into somebody they
should once they make it to the bone
marrow be safe now for in viewer appease
I think this is much more of a concern
because whether you introduce SP cast
line using nanoparticles or you
introduced sa cast line into somebody
using viruses the presence of
pre-existing immune responses means that
your immune system is going to be able
to respond very quickly any any cell
receives cast 9 and so you know in
previous clinical trials where for
instance somebody has had pre-existing
t-cell responses to an a I don't know
associated viral vector there has been
nullified
any therapeutic effect from treatment
because all the souls that received your
gene therapy adapter end up being
cleared from the body and you know you
can imagine even in you can imagine even
more severe cases where if you have lots
of cast 9 being expressed here you have
somebody was a very high responder to sa
cast line this wallets probably unlikely
you could even end up with a worst case
scenario of someone like Jessie Gilson
Gator who had you know a serious
inflammatory response to uni you know
the gene therapy he factor he received
in the 90s which resulted in his death
well I don't think anyone should panic
and that this is necessarily the
response I think this is something that
definitely has to be considered before
anyone goes into a clinical trial with
cast 9 and at least considered and
further studied to look and see if there
will be any adverse impacts from from
from these findings thank you for that
next one is are there any potential
methods to get around a pre-existing
adaptive immunity to Kaz 9 yes there are
a number of different methods that you
could take to try and get around this
you know one if there's an immuno
dominant epitope so a single part in
cast 9 or a couple of pots that are the
pieces that most people's immune system
are trained to target you could engineer
the cast on to be slightly different
around those areas now would that would
abolish any pre-existing immune response
you could use you could introduce T
regulatory cells that suppress adaptive
immune responses to cast 9 or you could
try and find cast 9 or other you know
site-specific nucleus is that God there
are no pre-existing immune responses so
you know for instance the first in vivo
gene gene therapy trial has already
begun it was put down by Sanger my
earlier this year um however they were
using zinc fingers which mostly use pots
from the human body and I don't think
there are any pre-existing immune
responses and so that is another way to
get around this issue thank you that
looks like we have time for one last
question can you comment on why you find
a higher frequency of antibodies against
cows 9 compared to t-cells
um so I think finding a higher frequency
of anybody's versus T cells is not
not surprising anybody's are
significantly easier to detect against
any antigen than T cells necessarily are
and there have even been you know again
you're going back to there's a be trials
there there were some cases where you
know a donor was ruled out as being
being negative for for having having an
immune response to the bar after they
used only for them to later find out
that you know the the person did have T
cells that were antigen specific against
their viral vector but they just hadn't
been able to identify them in their in
their initial Springs so I think it
makes sense that you know we find it's
easy to find antibodies which are lots
of proteins release into the blood then
you know a few very rare single cells
that can be why not single but very rare
in terms of proportion of the T cells in
the blood well I would like to once
again thank Carsten Charlesworth for his
presentation would also like to thank
laberd's for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January 3rd 2019 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay we share that
announcement when your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us we hope
to see you again soon bye